ah my bookshelves are so disorganized
must re-catalogue soon but there's no
time because pizzema starts in six days
good morning heck it's tuesday let's
talk about books specifically some great
books you probably haven't read
beginning with some fiction want to
spend some peaceful hours enjoying a
great mystery series crash course
co-founder stan muller introduced me to
ann swinfin's novels this book the
bookseller's tale is the first in my
favorite series it's set in oxford in
1353 and the world of medieval
bookmaking is just such a great backdrop
if you want to belly laugh and be truly
astonished by linguistic acrobatics i
recommend tough by paul beatty now
beatty is more famous for his books the
white boy shuffle and the booker award
winning the sellout but i first read
this book 20 years ago and i've been
thinking about it ever since a book that
makes me both sob and feel hopeful
jacqueline woodson's miracle boys this
novel is ostensibly for kids 10 and up
and i know many kids who've loved it but
i am a 44 year old person and i also
love it it's about impoverishment and
grief and surviving loss but above all
it is about brothers and hank as you
know i love a book about brotherhood and
this one might be my favorite okay onto
infectious disease because that's where
my brain always goes i really love the
book the black death by rosemary horrix
it's a collection of first-person
accounts of the four-year period in
which approximately half of all
europeans died of plague another disease
book i love is frank snowden's epidemics
and society it helped me understand that
infectious disease has like always been
one of the most important historical
forces like we think about alexander the
great and cleopatra and whatever but
it's mostly microbes and the book also
explores how racism and other forms of
discrimination shape disease burden
which in turn shapes history it's a
reminder that disease does not treat
people equally unless society treats
people equally a physics book i love the
disordered cosmos by chandra prescott
weinstein i think about it every day
this book taught me that we don't know
why there is matter in the universe
from which i have not recovered it also
helped me to understand the big bang and
dark energy and lots of other stuff even
though i have like a fourth grade level
of physics but it is also a book about
gender identity and race and lots of
other stuff it is just brilliant i have
never read anything like it another book
that acknowledges that we are not like
observers of reality but participants in
it phosphorescence by julia baird it's
about living with cancer and creatures
that make their own light and the
science of human joy and it is so so
good alright a sports book i realize i'm
biased here but all together now by
longtime afc wimbledon ceo eric
samuelson is so enjoyable i mean it is
the greatest underdog sports story of
all time told by one of the people who
made it happen essays i know mary oliver
is famous for her poems but i love her
essays especially the ones collected in
upstream i dog eared almost every page
of this book but one quote especially
stuck with me i read the way a person
might swim
to save his or her life speaking of that
kind of reading i love pilgrim bell the
new book of poems by kava akbar he
writes the kind of poems that get richer
and more interesting the more time you
spend with them and in the last month i
have read this book over and over and it
just keeps giving me new gifts lastly
you have probably not read this 1945
cookbook how to cook and eat in chinese
by bui young chao a chinese physician
who emigrated to the united states in
the 1920s this book has been out of
print for decades but it is a
wonderfully postmodern cookbook like one
of the first sentences in it is i did
not write this book it is also hugely
historically important it introduced
many americans to chinese cooking
techniques and coined english language
terms like stir fry and pot stickers and
it is full of these pithy witticisms
like you know how it is with modern
daughters and mothers who think we are
modern somebody put it back in print
what are some books i probably haven't
read that you would recommend to me let
me know in comments also i made a
bookshop.org list with all of these
books if you're interested plus a couple
other recommendations link in the
doobly-doo below hank i will see you on
friday and then you will see me on
monday